I've always been a games player that's
been my passion and I always wanted to
turn my hobby of playing games into the
business of making them and way back in
the 1970s I started a games company
called Games Workshop with a school
friend of mine Steve Jackson and we
moved out selling games that was
mail-order launched Dungeons & Dragons
we then took role-playing games to wider
audience by creating series of
interactive books called fighting
fantasy books in which you were the hero
killing monsters again and finding
treasure making a game experience of a
book confronted by fire-breathing
Gorgons you can look in your pack for
something to offer them 20 Papes 36 or
turn to page 90 draw your sword and
fight them one of those books is called
death trap dungeon and I was contacted
by a startup video game company called
Omar asked me to write story board and
design for their launch game Eureka
Eureka is great fun because I've been
playing computer games but didn't
anything about how to amaze I to work
with a team of programmers an artists
and making Eureka and saying there's a
completely different skill set and
especially one was a ethereal process
with millions of lines of code and I
couldn't go still can't code
strange science for someone of my age to
start earning now joined Omar I'm
selling out of Games Workshop and dome
art metamorphose into idose and i became
chairman of the new entity which was
floated on the London Stock Exchange and
then we acquired a studio it was
developing tomb raider and launched -
made it so this whole boom in the
console cycle I was very much part of
and very much enjoyed and realize what
an amazing talent this industry is huge
teams of artists and programmers and
artificial intelligence programs 3d
programmers to D programmers or the art
and animation and storyboarding and
narrative and camera and lighting and
you know physics and maths and the
compassion combination of art and
science that goes into making games like
making interactive cinema is it's it's
just extraordinary the skills required
to do that and is during this process of
developing games that I realized that
this simply weren't enough programmers
of the high enough caliber in the UK to
support an industry in which we got off
to such a flying start in the 80s now
this was down to programme have been
taught in schools
the BBC micro was a cornerstone of
computing in schools so it's not much to
look at but the beauty of it is you can
get into programming for easily doing
this and in the home everyone had a spec
18 affordable programmable computer
which cost not very much
and so we're after a wonderful start the
early days in the UK of games such as
manic miner and populist and then we
went through the tomb raids and grand
theft auto's are more recently moshi
monsters and and runescape and other
great successes but it could have been
so much more I was asked to chair skill
sets video game skills counsel looked at
all the universities which had games in
their title and found that for most part
they were not fit for purpose they
offered soft skills in the culture of
games the role of games in society and a
little bit of our design but they
weren't teaching what we need which was
the hard skills necessary to make the
games you know computer science coding
on animation and they were doing
students a great disservice because they
thought they're going to come out these
courses and immediately get jobs they
weren't because we effectively happened
to be retrained and of the 144 cases
that were listed skill set only
accredited ten of them as being fit for
purpose so I talked at length to advisee
the culture minister here in the UK
about this problem and he invited me and
Alex hail from double- to write a review
about the situation that review was
called next-gen
in a digital age schools and
universities are failing the creative
industry
next gem was a review with the main
recommendation to have CUDA science on
the on the school's National Curriculum
was essential discipline plus nineteen
other recommendations for government
industry and education and whilst it got
you know received well within our
industries it didn't really make
national headlines until Eric Schmidt's
chairman of Google reference next gen
and his met Taggart lecture I was
flabbergasted to learn that today
computer science is not even taught as
standard in UK schools now your IT care
curriculum by the way focuses on
teaching how do you software but it
doesn't teach people how it's made this
risks throwing away your great computing
heritage and of course if Eric said it
must be true and a month later the Prime
Minister echoed his words in his speech
at Tech City and we were suddenly
invited in to discuss computer science
and next-gen had highlighted not just
the probably need averse T's but the
cause that led to the lack of computer
science being taught in higher education
in further education that being the ICT
is currently taught was largely a
strange hybrid of office skills
kids were learning at school Word
PowerPoint and Excel they're using it
learning how to use technology what were
given no insight how to create their own
technology we were in effect teaching
them how to read but not how to write we
were making digital consumers but not
digital creators now the UK happens to
be pretty good at creativity look at our
film or fashion or music our design our
advertising and of course our games and
we're very good at high-technology
yet against all odds we've managed to
put kids off learning about how to
create technology despite them running
their lives through through smartphones
and social media and by the way we
taught
ICT at school so we need to excite them
to understand them to understand how to
create technology because as soon as you
get kids
coding it's just amazing the response
you get for them they've created
something they want to share something
you feel really special that that's your
game being played by different people I
would like to make games for people to
buy them all over the world and so
coding is at the heart of the world in
which they're going to exist they need
to be taught skills for jobs that don't
even exist today but what I don't want
it to be it's just another dry fourth
science what they should be doing is
having coursework assessed have their
code assessed working cooperatively
bringing academia the school environment
closer to the work environment something
that's relevant and in context fun and
something they've through peer to peer
learning there's so many creative ways
of learning together in school that
teachers shouldn't be afraid to have
children teach them effectively they can
be facilitators using the best online
resources where it's code Academy Khan
Academy or the informal clubs over here
like young rewires tked and KO club
there's amazing facilities to get kids
excited games are a perfect example of a
collaboration of two skills art and
science and it's not just about games
architecture you need the visual
aesthetic so a building looks beautiful
but you also need the mathematics to
make sure it doesn't fall down and kill
you so if you look around the whole
world where it's designing a car or a
plane or a smartphone device
it's that fusion of art and science it's
the steam agenda it's not the stem
agenda so science technology engineering
a mass of course essential but you have
to have art as part of that or a deep
understanding so that people can
collaborate computational thinking
problem-solving games based learning is
going to be all part of having somebody
has a more deeper understanding of the
problems that they need to solve in
their real worlds
for me an exam should if at all should
not be this memory test yeah question
one for a computer science exam should
not be who invented will word web
frankly I couldn't care less I can
google that and find out that in a
second it's where they can write some
code show me your code and I can give
you a job
wonderful people and all that I
understand all that then we need them
desperately but not everyone's going to
be an academic you have to so for me the
the the place where children learn has
to be brought closer to the place where
they're going to work so collaboration
as Ken Robin says it's not cheating it's
how the real world works so let them
learn together let them work together
don't judge them in isolation because we
are all different so it's about working
together with our own words it's just is
actually in going into the computer
games industry eventually